bonjour à tous bienvenue sur l'antenne
de public sénat dans quelques minutes
une dizaine de minutes place aux
traditionnelles questions d'actualité
sera large part évidemment aux questions
sociales sur la gravelle sncf les
intermittents mais on parlera également
de cette réforme territoriale dont on
parle énormément ici au sénat pour
discuter de tous ces thèmes je reçois
gérard larcher bonjour bonjour sénateur
ump des yvelines dans un instant jean
pierre sueur le président de la
commission des lois va nous rejoindre
pour parler de cette réforme
territoriale mais je voulais vous
entendre vous l'ancien ministre du
travail notamment sur cette question
aujourd'hui très importante tout d'abord
sur la sncf il reste à peu près une
dizaine de pourcents de grévistes est ce
que le gouvernement fait tout pour
arrêter la grève selon vous je pense que
le gouvernement
doit poursuivre bien évidemment l'examen
du texte à l'assemblée la réforme
nationale parce que la réforme est
nécessaire à mes yeux ne va pas assez
loin parce que ne prépare pas
suffisamment la sncf aux réalités de
2019 et de 2022 avec les réalités d'une
ouverture et en même temps il n'y a pas
d'autre voie me semble-t-il que tout en
poursuivant le dialogue social est bien
que les grévistes cesse leur grève qui
n'a plus de sens aujourd'hui et qui en
même temps n'apporte rien au débat donc
la fermeté du gouvernement apparaît
indispensable
je pense qui si vous êtes assez ferme je
suis à la fermeté du gouvernement était
indispensable s'il n'était pas ferme et
il en quelque sorte entraverait des
perspectives d'avenir pour la sncf mais
aussi pour d'autres réformes dont notre
pays a besoin le texte d'arriver au
sénat d'ici quelques semaines
quelle sera la position du groupe ump le
votera ou pas d'abord de voir l'état du
texte il arrivera bien sûr ensuite
savoir si le gouvernement sera attentif
à un certain nombre de nos propositions
vous savez le débat sur les scènes
siècle me fait penser à un débat que
nous avons eu sur la poste c'était il ya
un peu plus de 20 ans et j'en étais le
rapporteur et on avait hésité à l'époque
par les deux sociétés anonymes on y est
arrivé pourquoi dans notre pays serait
est-il si difficile d'envisager l'avenir
moi j'ai confiance en la sncf très
grandes entreprises nous avons un
formidable réseau nous sommes en avance
sur les autres sur les réseaux à grande
vitesse nous sommes en déficit sur le
secteur du fret et bien ce grand service
qui doit rester un service public comme
nous l'imaginons pourquoi at il peur de
son avenir
autre question bien entendu sur les
intermittents parce que ça fait partie
aussi état de crise sociale qui agite le
pays
virtuellement tous les festivals de
l'été sont remises en cause le premier
ministre doit s'exprimer en fin de
journée qu'est ce qui va se passer selon
vous d'abord c'est une crise que j'ai
connu il ya dix ans et à l'époque on
m'avait chargé de trouver une solution
je dois dire que j'ai prouvé qu'une
solution temporaire et est suffisante
c'est un sujet difficile
le premier ministre je pense doit gré
parce que sinon il remettra en cause
complètement de paritarisme l'accord des
partenaires sociaux parce que ne
l'oublions pas nous nous dirigeons vers
un déficit de l'unedic cumulé de 24
milliards avec la situation que nous
connaissons pour l'emploi et on ne peut
pas continuer à faire financer par des
salariés modestes du régime général le
régime des intermittents comme nous le
finançons aujourd'hui c'est une affaire
de justice et dans le sens des
intermittences énorme le sort des
intermittents c'est que rien ne bouge
donc sur ce sujet il faut à gré la
convention d'assurance chômage ensuite
je pense que le premier fils lancera une
négociation ils vont peut-être
réinventer un fonds que j'avais mis en
place je crois que l'essentiel c'est de
savoir comment financer une politique
culturelle on ne peut pas continuer à
voir des entreprises culturelles avoir
une entreprise de l'audiovisuel qui font
financer une partie de leur masse
salariale par les assurances chômage
payées par les salariés les entreprises
ça c'est indécent
on parle d'équité de justice s'est-il
équitable au bâton de 18 heures pour
voir le résultat des courses mais
visiblement vous avez l'air mais la
forme et je salue jean pierre sueur qui
met d'arrivée président ps de la
commission des lois bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous pour bien expliquer ce qui se
passe sur la réforme territoriale
ici au sénat parce que ça bouge beaucoup
je vous propose d'écouter les
explications de tram traduit elle est
actuellement dans l'hémicycle elle va
écouter évidemment les questions
d'actualité elle va vous résumer point
par point eh bien écoutez michael
effectivement la réforme territoriale
occupe beaucoup le sénat est aujourd'hui
il ya eu un coup de théâtre puisque l'on
a appris la constitution d'une
commission spéciale sur la réforme
territoriale
cette réforme pourtant et bien les
sénateurs avaient commencé à travailler
dessus avec les auditions hier de
bernard cazeneuve le ministre de
l'intérieur est également l'audition des
présidents de région mais tous ces
travaux avaient été faits au nom de la
commission des lois mais voilà que les
sénateurs du groupe communiste ceux du
groupe ump avec l'appui du groupe rds
seront pas majorité de radicaux de
gauche demande la constitution d'une
commission spéciale sur ce sujet par une
commission spéciale qu'est ce que c'est
c'est une commission transversale 1 qui
peut prendre des sénateurs dans toutes
les commissions et qui tient compte et
bien dans sa représentation du poids de
chaque groupe politique demande acceptée
voilà donc la commission des lois des
saisies le rapporteur initial michel
delebarre devrait devenir président de
cette commission spéciale toutefois que
rapporteur lui serait du groupe ump
alors à ce que c'est une tentative
d'obstruction comme l'ont dit certains
sénateurs socialistes de la commission
des lois est-ce que cela risque de faire
prendre du retard à l'examen du texte ça
nul ne le sait mais ce que l'on sait
c'est que la prochaine réunion de cette
commission spéciale c'est lundi à 17
heures merci merci c'est très clair
maintenant on m'a posé la question à nos
sénateurs pour avoir directement le
détail et notamment le président de la
commission des lois monsieur sueur est
ce que vous êtes flou et aujourd'hui ce
que vous sentez peut-être pas du tout
non vous êtes d'accord avec cette
commission spéciale et écouter des
collègues ont demandé cela nous avons
décidé de souscrire mais ça ne change
pas grand-chose voyez-vous votre c'est
d'être à votre consoeur a annoncé
que le futur rapporteur
serait différent de l'actuel mais vous
savez ça n'engage qu'elle il y aura une
commission spéciale et nous jouerons
complètement le jeu je crois que le
président d'une commission spéciale est
classiquement membres de l'opposition
le rapporteur de la majorité
il n'y a pas de raison de faire
autrement ce qui se passera c'est qu'au
lieu d'être 49 nous serons 37 nous avons
lancé les auditions un programme et sert
à cela cela sera légèrement remis en
cause mais soyons positifs il ya de
petites péripéties ce qui compte ce qui
compte c'est de moderne moderniser la
structure territoriale de notre pays pas
tout la réforme est celle qui consomme
est persuadé que la loi sera bien
examiné à partir du 1er juillet au sénat
mais oui puisque la manade retard mais
non le gouvernement et mettre de l'ordre
du jour pour ce qui concerne une session
extraordinaire
le texte a été inscrit et je vais vous
dire moi je suis heureux qu'on débatte
on n'a pas tous les mêmes idées mais
pour résumer en un mot on a besoin de
régions fortes je dis pas forcément des
régions avait beaucoup de kilomètres
carrés c'est des régions fortes des
régions qui est davantage de pouvoirs
que ce n'est le cas aujourd'hui
voyez-vous en allemagne les régions
je n'en doute pas j'en suis même sûr
mais les régions en allemagne ont dix
fois plus de ressources par habitant
qu'en france après il faut garder des
niveaux de proximité il y a les
départements les départements peuvent
subsister dans un certain nombre de
circonstances ils peuvent aussi voir
leurs compétences peut assumer par
d'autres niveaux par exemple des
communautés de communes jardin 6/11
métropole l'arabe et corrigé à l'arche
est enfin question aussi assez simple
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en train de
gagner du temps non la commission
spéciale je le souhaitais dans un
interview au journal l'opinion c'était
il ya tout juste un mois pourquoi
parce que les sujets de réforme
territoriale ce sont bien sûr des sujets
qui intéressent à commission des lois
mais qui vont beaucoup plus largement
que les seuls sujets de la commission
des lois a modifié la carte régionale
pour ensuite avoir un texte sur les
compétences ceux ci touchent la
commission des finances les conditions
financières la commission des affaires
économiques car il s'agit d'abord
d'économie quand on parle de compétence
économique s'agit aussi parce qu'on en a
très peu parlé des conséquences sociales
que vont devenir les fonctionnaires
territoriaux
voilà des vrais sujets j'ai souhaité la
commission spéciale qui est une manière
de travailler qui au contraire permet
d'embrasser l'ensemble du sujet et de
répondre quand même je le dis à jean
pierre sueur à une improvisation car
nous en sommes cher président quatrième
projet de réforme des collectivités
territoriales en 22 mois et j'avoue que
sur le sujet que le sénat ait souhaité
une commission spéciale que le président
du sénat est bien voulu le porter je
l'avais souhaité publiquement de même
que j'ai souhaité qu'on ne soit pas dans
une procédure accélérée
c'est essentiel il faut que la navette
ont bien sûr il y aura des lectures
normalement de lecture ça n'est pas la
même chose
la procédure normale on a même où je
sais pas si on l'appelle la procédure
normale et les devenu exceptionnel et ça
n'est pas sain pour le bic est une vraie
course d'elle c'est une vraie course
contre l'amiante revint beaucoup
d'arguties ce qu'il faut c'est
moderniser notre pays il avait dit
monsieur gillett à monsieur larcher
laisser le pourquoi
et oui mais attendez vous je vais vous
dire que vous avez raté en 2008 en 2006
je ne sais pas quand mais ça ne parle de
la loi que c'est ça cela ne mène à rien
ce qui est important cher président
larcher c'est qu'on se retrouve dans la
même commission et que l'honneur et que
l'on dise que les arguties les questions
de procédure sont finalement secondes ce
qui est important c'est de savoir si le
sénat comme on l'a fait pour les
métropoles sera trouvé
des majorités d'idées pour faire avancer
les choses et donc à cet égard moi j'y
vais dans un esprit constructif et
ouvert qu'est ce que vous faites des
auditions de bernard cazeneuve convié
hier le ministre de l'intérieur a porté
ce texte ce que vous faites de
l'audition des présidents qu'est ce que
nous en faisons mais vous rendez compte
nous avons invité les présidents de
région 10 sont venus 66 c'est à dire
qu'ils étaient contre la loire sont
venus les entendent pas du tout le débat
a été d'une grande richesse et ne s'est
pas limitée et j'en étais très heureux
aux questions de découpage et de
périmètre ça a été un débat constructif
les auditions continueront la semaine
prochaine et après on veut travailler
dans l'ouverture et moi je tiens
beaucoup à des régions qui soit solide
je vais vous dire pourquoi est forte
pour l'économie et l'emploi parce que
c'est ce qui intéresse nos compatriotes
gérard lafay de trois minutes à longwy
nous aborderons jeu j'en suis certain
les membres de la commission spéciale
dans un esprit constructif voilée dans
un esprit d'exigence
notamment absolue notamment quand on
voit d'accord ita d'étude d'impact
aujourd'hui quand on a vu le secrétaire
d'état monsieur vallini nous allons ses
confrères 25 milliards d'économies puis
10 milliards d'économies alors que le
sujet financier et de la maîtrise de la
dépense publique est un sujet essentiel
sur ce sujet nous serons exigeants qu'en
est-il réellement de la qualité de
l'étude d'impact d'autre part économie
c'est important mais aussi quelle
démocratie quelle démocratie mérite au
rial nous pouvons avoir est ce qu'on
veut une france qui seraient des no
man's land ruraux entre des métropole
attractive cette france-là - qui vit
dans une métropole je n'en veux pas
car ce qui m'intéresse c'est tout
d'abord les sachets à des anges les
moines a mûri dans un département rural
où il ya une grande agglomération je
n'en veux pas non plus
le service se retrouve le gouvernement
nous écoute les rondes
à côté d'une ambition pour le monde
urbain mais il faut une ambition pour
les deux c'est l'entente et là des
slogans moi c'est du concret que je veux
du concret notamment dans le domaine de
la proximité du social eh bien je sens
une grande désespérance du territoire
rural il n'est que de regarder comment
le territoire rural à voter aux
élections européennes pour entendre ce
cri mes angoisses cela vaut pour tout le
monde un pour tous les partis
républicains voilà le débat et on va
vous retrouver la démission on va suivre
tout ça avec les évidemment sur
l'antenne de public sénat je vous laisse
rejoindre l'hémicycle merci la
traditionnelle séance des questions
d'actualité
s'apprête à commencer le président jean
pierre bel est actuellement en train de
présider cette séance nous allons avoir
l'image à l'instant sur notre antenne
nous allons rejoindre cette séance ou
lire à de nombreuses questions notamment
sur l'aspect social sur la sncf il y
aura des questions aussi sur le problème
des intermittents du spectacle annoncé
tout à l'heure que le premier ministre
manuel valls s'exprimera en toute fin de
journée aux alentours de 18 heures et un
drap une conférence de presse après la
remise du rapport du député gilles qui
doit remettre ses conclusions sur ce
problème des intermittents du spectacle
et puis il y aura d'autres questions
évidemment surin levan très important
françois patriat le président de la
région bourgogne viendra s'expliquer
tout à l'heure sur notre plateau pour on
refait la séance la séance des traits
ans d'actualité les questions
d'actualité vont commencer d'ici peu de
temps les ministres présents elle durera
stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture jean marie le guen le
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement aurélie filippetti bien sûr
pour parler des intermittents du
spectacle et puis nous parlerons bien
entendu de ce problème des territoires
vous avez entendu ce débat qui a
commencé tout à l'heure nous allons tout
de suite retourné
dans les séances d'actualité
un petit peu de retard pour cette séance
de questions d'actualité qui est dû
certainement un petit problème
d'organisation ça va pas tarder à
s'organiser je vous rappelle tout
simplement tout à l'heure on va se
retrouver aux alentours de 16 heures
pour avoir une discussion beaucoup plus
large sur les problèmes sociaux qui
règne actuellement sur les grèves nous
parlerons évidemment avec roger
karoutchi allons peut-être un petit mot
de l'ump parce que vous savez aussi
qu'il ya toute cette affaire autour de
pygmalion qui gênent l'ump quid de
sarkozy qui a qui s'est exprimé dans le
figaro magazine où on parlera de tout ça
je vous le promets là jean pierre bel
qui va s'exprimer ministre mes chers
collègues lors de du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
je rappelle deux minutes trente pour le
ministre pour l'auteur de la question
la parole pour la première question un
géant longuet pour le groupe ump
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question à très
naturellement à l'actualité ferroviaire
et elle s'adresse
normalement à monsieur cuvillier absent
au rapport mais je suis persuadé que la
solidarité gouvernementale me permettra
d'avoir une réponse ma question n'a pas
trait à l'adaptation de la sncf à la
concurrence puisque le débat est
aujourd'hui ouvert à l'assemblée
nationale et que nous aurons à coeur de
le reprendre après les amendements que
vous aurez à proposer j'en suis
convaincu pour faciliter cette
négociation législatives difficiles ma
question n'a pas non plus très
pur relations difficiles entre les
organisations syndicales et en
particulier à l'intérieur de la cgt
entre le sommet et la base où
manifestement le manque de coordination
abouti à une paralysie ferroviaire ma
question a trait à la façon dont le
gouvernement entend ne pas imposer aux
usagers des chemins de fer qu'ils vivent
une véritable calvaire et en particulier
en région parisienne ou pour les usagers
du ter mais également pour les usagers
des grandes lignes ne pas leur imposer
une double peine cette double peine
consiste dans un premier temps alors
rendre la vie à peu près impossible d'en
l'imprévisibilité et dans l'abandon de
l'esprit du service public et dans un
deuxième temps à leur adresser la
facture en augmentant ou en tous les cas
soient les impôts soit la tarification
ferroviaire car monsieur le président la
sncf monsieur pépy viennent nous
indiquer que cette opération lui a déjà
coûté 150 millions d'euros à 20 millions
par jour on peut penser que s'il n'y a
pas de solution
le chiffrage dépassera très largement
les capacités de la sncf dès maintenant
monsieur cuvillier a annoncé que les 500
millions de dividendes que la sncf
aurait pu apporter à l'état
disparaîtront et donc nous avons une
double peine puisque nous avons des
usagers qui sont privés d'un service et
des contribuables ainsi que des clients
de la sncf qui auront vocation à payer
la différence alors monsieur le ministre
quel va être votre attitude et comment
amènerez vous l'entreprise à prendre sa
part de responsabilité
sachant que ses marges de manoeuvre sont
à peu près nulles
merci pour vous répondre la parole à
jean marie le guen secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gérard longuet votre question
effectivement porte sur les
inconvénients du mouvement social actuel
et je voudrais vous dire évidemment que
deux organisations syndicales et un
certain nombre de salariés effectivement
manifestent en effet leur inquiétude
depuis plusieurs jours sur l'avenir du
système ferroviaire et j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir s'agissant des
perturbations pour nos compatriotes
elles sont indiscutablement importante
même si en moyenne moins de 20% des
salariés la sncf ont fait grève cette
dernière semaine 10 ennemis %
aujourd'hui
conformément à la législation en vigueur
vous le savez monsieur le sénateur il
n'y a pas de service minimum mais la
sncf met en place a mis en place un plan
de transport adapté apporte chaque jour
une information la plus complète
possible sur les circulations
alors monsieur le sénateur vous
constatez un mouvement social comme nous
tous mais vous le savez ce mouvement
social vient au moment où nous faisons
une loi qui vise à répondre à un certain
nombre d'inquiétudes profonde qui
étaient ceux de des salariés de la sncf
à l'issue d'une autre loi qui avait été
adoptée par votre majorité à l'époque et
qui les avaient plongés dans ses doutes
très profond nous avons donc une loi qui
aujourd'hui vous le savez réunira le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure
ferroviaire qui est aujourd'hui
malheureusement éclaté et rassemblera
dans un même epix gestionnaire
d'infrastructure son principal
utilisateur la sncf et donc nous allons
faire en sorte que l'état reprend sa
place à l'intérieur de la stratégie
nationale du ferroviaire nous allons
créer un grand groupe public et
industriel capable d'être un acteur
majeur sur le plan européen et mondial
et nous garantissons un cadre social
commun pour protéger les cheminots alors
bien évidemment je pense que nous
pouvons espérer que dans les heures qui
viennent ce mouvement se termine et au
total nous aurons je le crois avec des
preuves tout à fait concrète inscrite
dans la loi redonner confiance aux
cheminots et aux cheminots dans l'avenir
de leur entreprise
merci la parole est à yves pozzo di
borgo pour le groupe udc
monsieur le président madame la miss mes
chers collègues des philippines à
l'afrique en passant par la chine le
pakistan l'iran l'irak l'arabie saoudite
ont l'impression que sur divers chrétien
s'est abattue sur une partie du globe en
2013 on a pu dénombrer 2123 assassinats
de chrétiens chiffres connus dont la
plupart hanté par prêter dans l'air
arabo musulmane sans compter les
chiffres de 2014 crise est plus
important compte tenu des tensions entre
sunnites et chiites
on pourrait considérer que cela est une
accumulation des faits diverge qui
touche toutes les religions comme
l'assassinât hier dans l'essex en
angleterre d'un jeune musulman mais
quand on regarde les chiffres de départ
massif des chrétiens d'orient sur des
terres sur lesquelles ils vivent depuis
toujours nous ne pouvons que nous
interroger en irak en comptait 5
millions de chrétiens 2003 il semblerait
qu on y arrive et alfie 250000 en 1950
on aurait pu jusqu'à 20 % de chrétiens
dans ces zones il ne pourrait en europe
plus représenté que 3 4% la population
2025 en ce qui concerne l'afrique
d'après les ong portes ouverts en france
a classé les 50 pays du monde la
persécution chrétienne a plus remarqué
le continent africain il représente avec
au total 17 pays nous avons tous en
mémoire le 14 avril dernier le cas des
200 lycéenne nigériane qui ont été
enlevés par la secte boko haram et sont
menacés à cause de leur foi chrétienne
dans un pays où l'intolérance à conduire
de nombreux assassinats et dernière
après une vaste campagne de
sensibilisation le silence et s'y est
installé
en fait nous avons tous été frappés dans
cet hémicycle parle atrocités vécues en
ce moment pameri amaya ibrahim sy scac
jeunes musulmanes soudanaise devenue
chrétienne de 27 ans enceinte qui a été
condamné à mort il ya peu moins de deux
semaines pour apostasie et dont on
attend qu'elle est finie d'allaiter pour
la prendre comment ce genre de situation
peut elle exister dans le monde au 20e
siècle
21e pardon pour mener l'action du
gouvernement sur ces deux cas nous
savons qu'il ya eu des initiatives mais
plus généralement est ce que l'ensemble
de ces faits ça c'est la diplomatie
française à nous répondre 2 doivent-ils
être relativisée parce que ça se passe
dans des pays où la tension est forte ou
est-ce que c'est intéressant que je pose
madame la ministre je vous propose le
est ce que c'est un phénomène plus
globale et plus marquants et dans ces
cas là quelle est la réaction de la
diplomatie française notamment avait des
pays avec lesquels nous avons des
relations très étroites voilà merci
merci madame annick jardin secrétaire
d'état chargé du développement de la
francophonie monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateurs il faut sonder borgo
d'abord monsieur le sénateur
permettez-moi d'excusés le ministre des
affaires étrangères laurent fabius qui
en ce moment à l'elysée où se tient un
conseil restreint de défense sur l'irak
je veux rappeler ici que la france
république laïque défends partout dans
le monde la liberté de religion ou de
conviction
concrètement elle intervient lorsque ces
principes sont menacés pour rappeler les
états concernés à leur devoir assurer le
libre exercice des cultes pour tous les
citoyens éliminer toutes les
discriminations fondées sur la religion
ou la conviction notre politique envers
les communautés chrétiennes d'orient
s'inscrit dans ce cadre elle exclut elle
inclut le respect des droits des
personnes appartenant aux minorités
religieuses et prend en compte les liens
spécifiques hérités de l'histoire
notamment les au liban en irak en egypte
en turquie en syrie ou en israël et dans
les territoires palestiniens
nous connaissons leurs inquiétudes en
cette période cruciale nous sommes
vigilants quant à leur situation le
président de la république a évoqué ce
sujet au vatican le 24 janvier dernier
avec le pas françois en centrafrique
nous soutenons l'action de
réconciliation des responsables
religieux centrafricain catholique
protestant et musulman ils ont compris
que le conflit actuel n'est pas et ne
doit pas devenir une guerre de religion
leur tâche est essentielle retour à la
paix civile la force africaine et la
force française protège toutes les
populations quelle que soit leur
confession ou leur origine concernant le
nigeria la france a condamné avec
fermeté le terrorisme de boko haram
notamment l'enlèvement des deux cents
jeunes écolières le président de la
république a réuni au sommet le 17 mai
dernier un sommet le 17 mai dernier à
paris on peut s'en féliciter qui a
permis d'intensifier la coopération
régionale pour lutter contre le
terrorisme j'ai personnellement
participé le 12 juin dernier à la
réunion de suivi organisée à londres qui
a permis de maintenir la mobilisation et
c'est important dans ce pays chrétiens
et musulmans veulent dans leur immense
majorité vivre en paix et sans
conjointement victimes du terrorisme et
il faut le rappeler enfin la france a
condamné la décision de la justice
soudanaise d'infliger la peine de mort à
une jeune femme pour apostasie vous
l'avez dit nous appellerons les
autorités soudanaises à garantir la
liberté de religion ou de conviction
conformément au pacte international
relatif aux droits civils et politiques
ratifié par le soudan nous serons
attentifs monsieur sénateurs au sud de
la procédure judiciaire concernant cette
jeune soudanaise ont un lien étroit avec
nos partenaires européens cette décision
qui heurte les consciences et qui
suscite une émotion totalement légitime
voilà monsieur le sénateur ce que fait
la france fidèle à ses valeurs
fondatrices que sont la liberté et la
conscience et la conscience et la
conscience et la laïcité merci merci
merci la parole à présent à richard ue
pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
porte sur l'évasion des capitaux hors de
france
je vous rappelle l'excellent rapport de
nos collègues
ok et dominati
qui avait en 2012 chiffrer cette évasion
est ce le manque de recettes pour l'état
à 32 ou 36 milliards d'euros somme tout
à fait considérable si on disposait de
cette somme ne saurions déjà à plus à
l'aise pour résoudre les questions
budgétaires
face à ce fléau la france s'est dotée
des moyens d'agir nous avons la
circulaire de 2013 qui a mis en place
une procédure de rapatriement de ces
fonds qui fonctionne semble-t-il plutôt
bien nous avons la loi de décembre 2013
qui aggrave les sanctions
nous avons été très actifs dans la mise
en place de l' échange automatique de
données fiscales qui porte
le mot l'acronyme américain donc
j'ose à peine le citer mais enfin cela
s'appelle fatca
ça n'est pas religieux c'est purement
fiscal
et nous en espérons des résultats et
j'ajoute que la loi bancaire que nous
avons tous voté en juin 2013 oblige les
banques à donner des informations
entre autres fiscale pays par pays
d'ici depuis le début de l'année environ
23000 dossier de rapatriement ont été
enregistrés à à bercy
et ceci se traduit par une plus value de
recettes de l'ordre de 1 milliard
d'euros probablement un peu plus qu'un
milliard d'euros de recettes
supplémentaires par rapport à la loi de
finances initiale ces sommes récupérées
et rapatrié vont évidemment alimenter le
budget vont alimenter
lisf et vont permettre une baisse de
l'impôt pour environ quatre millions de
foyers modestes c'est du moins ce qui
est prévu dans le projet de loi et de
finances rectificative que je suis sur
tout le monde votera ici voilà une
politique plus juste et plus efficace
que celle du bouclier fiscal qui n'a
jamais fait revenir personnes
ni même de l'exit tax que personne ne
connaît mais qui n'a jamais empêché qui
que ce soit de quitter la france j'en
reviens à ma question question monsieur
le ministre
disposez vous de nouvelles évaluations
de recettes pour l'ensemble de l'année
monsieur le ministre quand sera fatca
quand sera mis en place définitivement
24 et enfin c'est une question liée
pouvons nous agir pour limiter le
dumping fiscal entre les pays de l'union
je pense simon shaw loge dans les
sociétés mercier à la fiscalité pour les
retraites au portugal est bien la parole
et à cristie kerr
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le sénateur pour cette question
qui me permet d'informer votre assemblée
sur l'activité du gouvernement dans un
domaine ou quels jeux vous c'est
particulièrement attentifs s'agissant de
la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
s'agissant des recettes attendues
c'était votre première question les
recettes attendues de l'activité dues et
ce tdr c'est l'acronyme utilisés ont été
revues à la hausse pour 2014 2 1
milliards d'euros elles sont désormais
prévues à hauteur de 1,8 milliard
d'euros au 13 juin
dernier le spdr comptabilisé 1946
millions d'euros de recettes
ces recettes constitue consiste
essentiellement en un surplus d'impôt
sur le revenu de droits de succession de
donation et 10 sf pour 2015 le montant
exact la recette reste encore incertain
il est probable plus que probable qu'ils
se maintiendra à un niveau élevé compte
tenu du stock de dossiers en instance de
traitement à savoir plus de 20 mille
dossiers avec une moyenne d'avoir par
dossier de l'ordre d'un million d'euros
900 milles plus exactement une partie de
cette recette sera pérenne puisque
si je fais un calcul basiques sur vingt
mille dossiers de 1 million d'euros soit
environ 20 milliards d'euros d'avoirs
souvent le plus souvent un sujet qui
allie sf et donc qui donneront lieu
probablement une recette pérenne de
l'ordre de 200 millions d'euros et une
estimation
que nous affinerons au fil du temps sur
votre deuxième point je voudrais vous
dire que lutter contre la fraude c'est
d'abord lutter contre l'opacité
favoriser la transparence à ce titre la
france avec ses partenaires européens du
g5 à bousculer les agendas du g20 et de
l'union pour faire de l' échange
automatique le futur standard mondial en
matière d'échangé d'informations
fiscales parce que c'est le moyen le
plus efficace de faire reculer le secret
bancaire les résultats sont au
rendez-vous le g20 a approuvé un nouveau
standard mondial et universel mais au
profit de tous il est préparé par l'os
et des oeufs et il verra le jour d'ici
2015 pour encourager son adoption le
plus rapidement possible ce groupe des 5
à fédérer autour de lui un groupe de 40
à 44 pardon et à et juridictions qui
s'engagent à mettre en oeuvre ce
standard entre 2015 et 2016 de façon
volontaire enfin au sein de l'union la
france obtenu qu'une directive soit
révisée celle sur la coopération
administrative pour incorporer ce
standard au sein du droit de l'union et
le conseil européen s'est prononcé à
l'unanimité pour que la directive soit
adoptée fin 2014 il faut aussi échangé
le sujet les singles fiscale c'est ce
que nous faisons au travers des travaux
notamment de l' ocde sur le chantier
baisse vous voyez que le gouvernant est
complètement mobilisée avec le parlement
dont nous attendons bien sûr les mesures
législatives qui les accompagnent merci
la parole à andré gattolin pour le
groupe écologiste
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du travail de
l'emploi et du dialogue social monsieur
il n'est pas là il sera remplacé par la
ministre de la culture mais monsieur le
ministre la nouvelle convention unedic
qui est à présent soumises à votre
agrément prévoir en ce qui concerne les
techniciens du spectacle et les articles
et les artistes d'importantes
restrictions de leurs conditions
d'indemnisation et de leurs droits
sociaux face au risque d'une
précarisation accrue de ces acteurs
déterminants de notre vie culturelle de
nombreuses voix s'élèvent aujourd'hui
pour appeler le gouvernement à suspendre
l'agrément de cet accord à plusieurs
reprises vous avez déclaré devant nos
collègues députés que cet accord était
majoritaire est donc légitime bien
monsieur le ministre nous avons nous le
sentiment que le fonctionnement de la
démocratie sociale en france sur ce
point n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
faut-il ici rappeler l'impact décisif de
la culture et de ces intermittents pour
le dynamisme économique de nos
territoires
alors pourquoi autour de la table des
négociations les représentants des
salariés de ce secteur les employeurs
culturel où les collectivités publiques
qui finance pour pratiquement la moitié
le secteur du spectacle vivant n'ont
pratiquement pas eu un mot à dire
pourquoi les propositions alternatives
celle du comité de suivi comme celle de
notre collègue maryvonne blondin que je
salue ici en particulier les
propositions 3 4 6 et 9 de son rapport
sont-elles balayé d'un revers de main
par les instances paritaires il ne
s'agit pas ici de défendre le statu quo
mais l'ouverture d'une véritable
négociation sur l'emploi intermittents
car à coût constant d'autres solutions
existent qui remette à plat le
dispositif en vigueur être plus de
solidarité et dans le respect de
l'attachement de notre pays à la culture
et aux artistes la mission de
conciliation sans feuille de route
formelle que vous avez récemment confié
un autre collègue le député jean patrick
gille s'oriente vous le savez vers un
échec en grande partie parce que le
gouvernement a d'ores et déjà annoncé à
plusieurs reprises sa décision coûte que
coûte d'agréer la convention unedic
avant le 30 juin vouloir satisfaire les
exigences du medef avant l'ouverture
début juillet de la conférence sociale
plutôt que d'apporter une réponse
équitable à la question de
l'intermittence risque de balayer du
paysage les petites compagnies du
spectacle vivant et de fragiliser nombre
de structures déjà exemple
financièrement alors monsieur le
ministre à balle est dans votre camp
êtes-vous prêt à repousser l'agrément
des annexes litigieuse de cette
convention pour engager de véritables
discussions avec les acteurs eq te ment
concernés par ces mesures et permettent
d'éviter l'annulation de la
quasi-totalité des festivals cet été je
vous remercie merci merci la parole est
à madame aurélie filippetti ministre la
culture de la communication
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur andré gattolin
vous parlez de l'accord du 22 mars c'est
un accord signé par les partenaires
sociaux vous le savez ce sont les règles
du dialogue social les règles du
paritarisme qui ont établi des
dispositions qui s'appliquent à
l'ensemble des chômeurs de ce pays à
l'ensemble des gens qui touchent des
indemnités chômage dans ce pays
quatre millions de personnes à
l'intérieur duquel effectivement il y à
des artistes et des techniciens du
spectacle auquel nous sommes plus que
jamais attachés j'ai été l'une des
premières a soulevé la difficulté que
pose et cette mesure de différé qui est
l'une des trois mesures présentes dans
l'accord et qui concerne les
intermittents cette mesure a été modifié
elle continue à inquiéter le
gouvernement en temps en temps
l'inquiétude de ces artistes et de ses
techniciens qui font la vie de nos
territoires qui font la vie de nos
festivals et partout ici sur ces bancs
nous savons combien la france doit à la
culture parce que la france est une
grande nation par son patrimoine par son
héritage mais aussi par la vitalité de
sa création est de ces artistes
nous avons
nous avons à la fois le souci de
respecter le dialogue social et en même
temps le souci exigeant l'impérieuse
nécessité de trouver une solution pour
ce régime de l'intermittence qui
régulièrement périodiquement suscite des
crises et des 5 et des inquiétudes il
faut le réformer il faut le remettre à
plat et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement le premier ministre s'est
exprimée fortement c'est pour sortir de
cette difficulté que nous avons confié à
jean patrick gille ce député qui connaît
aussi bien l'ensemble de l'unedic que le
fonctionnement des annexes 8 et 10 nous
lui avons confié une mission de
médiation et de proposition et je vous
l'annonçais monsieur le sénateur son
rapport son travail sera rendu cet après
midi même au premier ministre et au
ministre du travail et à moi-même et le
premier ministre s'exprimera à 18h ce
soir pour indiquer les conclusions les
lignes qu'il tire de ce rapport et la
manière dont nous allons tous ensemble
et y compris avec vous les
parlementaires sauver les artistes et
les techniciens de ce pays
merci la parole est à thierry foucaud
pour le groupe crc
si monsieur le président madame la
ministre
le mouvement de grève des intermittents
du spectacle démontre s'il en était
besoin que la culture ne peut pas vivre
sans eux ils demandent que le
gouvernement n'agrée pas le nouvel
accord sur le régime d'assurance-chômage
du 22 mars car cet accord entérine
madame la ministre les régressions de la
réforme de 2003 qui je le rappelle avait
alors été combattu par toute la gauche
mais en plus il aggrave en précarisant
encore plus les artistes et techniciens
bénéficiaires de l'assurance chômage il
entérine aussi le calcul des 507 heures
sur 10 mois et 10 mois et demi la
suppression de la date anniversaire et
du calcul des droits à dax fisc tout en
instaurant une sur cotation de deux
points pour les employeurs et les
intermittents ainsi que de nouvelles
règles de calcul du différé
d'indemnisation qui vont placer 47% des
intermittents du spectacle au lieu de 9
actuellement sans indemnisation chômage
ni revenu pendant des périodes pouvant
aller jusqu'à 45 jours les intermittents
demande donc ouverture de nouvelles
discussions examinant les propositions
alternatives formulées depuis 11 ans qui
ont fait l'objet de nombreux rapports
dont le dernier du syndeac qui démontre
qu'il est possible de rétablir le
caractère mutualiste de ce régime mais
de garantir également plus d'équité dans
les règles d'accès et d'indemnisation
tout en assurant un meilleur équilibre
et qu'on mik le gouvernement face à la
montée des protestations
vous l'avez dit madame la ministre a
nommé un médiateur qui doit rendent
d'ailleurs son rapport la semaine
prochaine nous at on dit sans anticiper
sur
cet après midi sans anticiper sur ces
conclusions je vous le dis il est
illusoire d'envisager mettre fin à ce
conflit sans renoncer à cet accord un
juste son fondement est mauvais il ne
peut donc ni être aménagés ni doit être
retardée il doit être refondée il faut
de véritables négociations qui
envisagent cette fois l'ensemble des
propositions alternatives formulée sans
exclusive ni parti pris le ministre du
travail indiqué le 9 mars dernier dans
une tribune dans laquelle comme nous
aujourd'hui il dénonçait les conditions
dans lesquelles ces négociations avaient
lieu est appelé à une nouvelle réforme
vous venez de le faire également un
instant c'est pourquoi madame la
ministre vous avez aujourd'hui le
pouvoir de la réaliser c'est pourquoi je
vous le demande allez vous enfin renoncé
à l'agrément de cet accord
merci la parole à aurélie filippetti
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur thierry foucaud je connais
votre attachement comme suit de tous les
parlementaires à la situation des
artistes et des techniciens de ce pays
je veux redire encore une fois que ses
artistes et ses techniciens qu'on
appelle les intermittents ce sont des
hommes et des femmes qui travaillent
pour faire vivre la culture dans tous
les territoires ce ne sont pas des
privilégiés
ce sont des gens qui ont des conditions
de vie de travail extrêmement spécifique
et avec une grande précarité cette
précarité elle s'est accrue il y a eu
depuis dix ans
d'innombrables travaux qui ont été menés
les travaux du comité de suivi les
travaux des missions parlementaires
celle de maryvonne blondin ici au sénat
celle de jean patrick gille et de
christian kert à l'assemblée nationale
il ya les propositions du syndeac nous
avons tous évidemment un corpus de
mesure de réflexion pour pouvoir enfin
rebâtir un système qui donne une
véritable sécurité professionnelle à ses
artistes et à ses techniciens et en même
temps évidemment qui préserve la
vitalité de notre tissu créatif en
france jean patrick gille dans sa
mission de médiation a rencontré tous
les acteurs de la discussion tous les
acteurs de la négociation
son travail qu'il va rendre donc cet
après midi même et non pas la semaine
prochaine il a été évidemment nourris de
son expérience mais nourrit aussi de
tous les travaux qui ont précédé ce
travail il sera suivi d' annonce par le
premier ministre pour répondre à un
double objectif sortir de la crise dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons est
évidemment préserver la vie de nos
festivals pour que on n'entende pas
raisonner le silence et la mort et la
tristesse cet été dans les rues de nos
villes
que ce soit évidemment avignon aix mais
aussi aurillac marciac partout en france
il y à des festivals formidable nous
allons donc sortir de la crise c'est le
but de ce rapport mais aussi refonder
refonder profondément un système plus
juste plus équitable pour protéger de
cette précarité les artistes et les
techniciens du spectacle et de
l'audiovisuel
c'est absolument indispensable
il n'est pas normal que régulièrement
reviennent ce genre de crise et que nous
ne puissions pas collectivement trouver
des solutions nous avons tous nous avons
besoin d'un régime spécifique
d'indemnisation du chômage pour les
artistes et pour les techniciens nour il
nous reste à bâtir ensemble la manière
d'y arriver c'est ce qu'a dit le
gouvernement c'est ce qu'a dit le
premier ministre une grande réforme est
nécessaire et l'état évidemment le
gouvernement prend toutes ses
responsabilités pour que chacun puisse
se remettre autour de la table et qu'on
trouve une solution ensemble
merci la parole à christian bourquin
pour le perdez c'est ma question
s'adresse aux premiers ministres
tant que président de région il y a déjà
plusieurs années que je plaide pour le
plus grand de décentralisation conforme
aux attentes des français en matière de
proximité et d'efficacité
je ne suis donc pas opposé à une réforme
réorganise en notre république
décentralisée et permettant de faire des
économies
hélas je ne vois pas dans votre réforme
le grand big bang territorial espéré
depuis plusieurs semaines il n'est
question que d'arithmétique sur le
nombre de régions
alors que la question sur les
compétences et les moyens des
collectivités primordial on ne nous
parle que de découpeurs voire de
découpage des questions demeurent ainsi
un suspens la décision de faire
disparaître les conseils généraux sans
même donner le temps aux
intercommunalités de se préparer ne
va-t-elle pas de condamner les
territoires hyper euros que dirait que
faire des milliers de fonctionnaires
concernés j'en arrive si vous le
permettez au sort réservé à certaines
régions au le languedoc roussillon par
exemple où la désapprobation est très
très très forte pourquoi faire
disparaître la région la plus attractive
de france
qui voit venir en moyenne trente mille
nouveaux habitants s'établir chaque
année c'est également le même nombre
d'entreprises qui sont créées chaque
année de l'emploi de l'emploi de
l'emploi pourquoi risquer de donner un
coup d'arrêt à des politiques innovantes
en faveur du pouvoir d'achat comme celle
du train un euro sur tout le territoire
de la région pourquoi condamner et sud
de france est notre marque connue et
reconnue à l'international
c'est important le commerce extérieur
l'un d'eux roussillon à toutes ses
forces vives qui conteste votre décision
l'argument démographique ne tient pas
nous avons autant d'habitants que
l'aquitaine et la bretagne deux parmi
les sept régions épargnées par le
découpage le contact et je le sais je le
mesure est aussi tendue je le sais en
picardie et dans l'ouest de la france
nous n'avons à l'angle en russie ont
rien contre le voisin me pyrénées nous
refusons simplement le mariage forcé
nous n'avons pas la même histoire
n'ont pas la même dynamique économique
n'ont même pas la même logique de
développement
avant nous en effet il faut le prendre
en compte construit notre identité du
xxème siècle sur nos atouts et nos
spécificités alors ma question monsieur
le premier ministre saurez vous tenir
compte des voix qui remonte de nos
régions
le 06 en tête durant les débats
parlementaires
monsieur le premier ministre saurez vous
accompagner le changement tant réclamée
sur le terrain
ce changement nécessaire mais pas
conforme à vos dernières décisions merci
la parole est à marylise lebranchu du
ministre la décentralisation de la
fonction publique merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur christian
bourquin c'est au sénat le 8 janvier
dernier
que avec une affluence importante
les parlementaires ont proposé au
président de la république
sous l'autorité d'un rapport reconnu
comme par sa qualité signé à la fois par
monsieur raffarin monsieur krattinger de
diminuer le nombre de régions de france
nous avons eu
cela mais cela ne vous énervez pas
besoin j'y viens j'y viens j'y viens
monsieur larcher l'île de batz n'est pas
concerné mais
dans ce débat important il y avait deux
éléments avoir moins de région pour
essayer d'avoir des régions de taille
dite européenne et
garder ou non les départements et c'est
là que d'ailleurs de façon très
très transversale
de façon très transparente izan
nom me suivrait un peu de respect disait
votre collègue de façon très
transparente izan sur des banques comme
sur les autres les positions ont été
extrêmement partagées il y avait autant
de voix à droite qu'à gauche pour dire
on supprime les départements et vice et
versa donc un dossier difficile le
président de la république le 14 janvier
ayant d'ailleurs
écouter les débats du sénat a proposé
qu'on réduise le nombre de régions il
était parti de 10 11 et puis à proposer
14 régions ensuite question a été posée
concernant les départements je pense que
nos débats seront ici extrêmement
intéressant sur le sujet et le premier
ministre manuel valls au vu et de toutes
vos réactions a décidé de prolonger
entre guillemets les départements
jusqu'en 2020 pour que nous ayons
communément le temps de voir si on les
supprime sur les zones urbaines ce qui
est la position majoritaire des
parlementaires de manière générale en
les gardant sur les zones rurales ou si
on trouve un autre échelon de
discussions de proximité
monsieur le président christian bourquin
vous avez l'occasion avec votre
conférence territoriale de l'action
publique déjà d'anticiper
ce sujet puisque vous pouvez réunir
l'ensemble de vos exécutif et en parler
je voudrais simplement vous dire que
nous avons ensemble a parlé du
redressement de la france vous avez de
très très beaux fleurons dans votre
région comme dans d'autres nous avons
aussi un taux de chômage extrêmement
important il est temps sans doute qu'on
reparle de politique industrielle et
peut-être que cet ensemble qu'on vous
proposer de qualité en tout cas et je
veux conclure sur ce sujet le ministre
de l'intérieur qui s'excuse d'être à
mayotte aujourd'hui sur un dossier aussi
important sera présent et vous dira une
position du gouvernement mais les sera
totalement naturellement ouvert le débat
au sénat merci la parole à elisabeth
lamure pour le groupe peu
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre du logement en effet très
récemment le ministre de l'économie a
reconnu devant des journalistes que le
marché du logement allait mal alors cet
aveu rejoint malheureusement la profonde
inquiétude des constructeurs comme celle
des agents immobiliers et nous
commençons ainsi à payer la politique
menée par le gouvernement la matière et
en particulier avec la loi allure
présentée et défendue par votre
prédécesseur ce monstre juridique de
plus de 150 articles fruit d'un
compromis politique avec la frange la
plus idéologique de la majorité est en
train de créer une crise du logement
sans précédent en france pourtant que
n'avons nous adresser comme
avertissement au gouvernement sur les
dangers économiques et les aberrations
administratives de ce texte le résultat
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les investisseurs
ne veulent pas faire construire et les
propriétaires ont peur de mettre en
location les chiffres sont là d'ailleurs
pour le prouver des chiffres communiqués
par le commissariat au développement
durable en un an entre mai 2013 et avril
2014 le nombre de logements neufs mises
en chantier affichent un recul de 6 et
demi pour cent c'est un triste record et
plus grave encore les logements
commencés sur les trois derniers mois
sont en baisse de 17,6 pour cent par
rapport à la même période en 2013 et à
l'urgence sociale qui découlera de cette
tendance se rajoute le discrédit
politique pour françois hollande qui
annonçait au cours de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 je le cite
j'agirai pour que soient construits au
cours du quinquennat deux millions et
demi de logements intermédiaires sociaux
et étudiants soit 300 milles de plus que
lors du quinquennat précédent encore une
promesse de campagne non tenues
malheureusement au rythme actuel de 315
mille logements mis en chantier par an
vous ne dépasserez même pas 1 million
700 mille logements construits sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat alors que 2,2
millions de logements ont été construits
entre 2007 et 2012 comme le reconnaît le
président de la république madame la
ministre vous vous rendez demain dans
mon département pour clôturer à lyon le
congrès de la fédération des promoteurs
immobiliers dans ce contexte quels
correctifs très attendue de la loi
allure comptez vous annoncer de façon à
remédier si possible à la crise du
logement qui frappe durement les
français je vous remercie merci la
parole à sylvia pinel ministre du
logement et de l'égalité des territoires
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice elisabeth lamure le la crise
du logement mérite un effet que nous
puissions travailler et nous rassembler
pour trouver les solutions les plus
appropriées à l'accès au logement à la
fois pour les français qui sont en
attente de l'attribution d'un logement
social mais aussi pour ce secteur
économique indispensable à la vitalité
de nos territoires et à la création
d'emploi vous le savez le secteur du
bâtiment de la construction est très
pourvoyeur d'emplois et vous avez plus
précisément évoquer la situation du
logement du logement social et justement
l'union sociale pour l'habitat le
mouvement hlm ainsi que mes services on
m'a alerté sur la diminution depuis une
période récente suite au changement de
certaines municipalités du retard ou de
l'abandon de certains programmes de
logements sociaux
il est donc important et je vous rejoins
madame la sénatrice que nous puissions
travailler ensemble pour ne pas retarder
ces loges ces chantiers pour trouver les
solutions adaptées lorsque de manière
légitime un certain nombre de maires
peuvent rencontrer des difficultés pour
créer tous les équipements qui sont
liées au logement vous m'avez plus
particulièrement interrogé sur la mise
en oeuvre la mise en application de la
loi allure cette loi a été votée
récemment
le parlement est comme le premier
ministre l'a rappelé hier il est de la
responsabilité du gouvernement de la
mettre en oeuvre et comme vous le savez
aussi plus de 200 mesures d'application
sont nécessaires avec une centaine de
décrets et nous avons commencé ce
travail et nous avons priorisé les
textes d'application
ceux qui sont prioritaires et urgents
pour redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français mais vous ne pouvez pas laisser
dire que un certain nombre de
ralentissement serait constatée serait
lié à une loi qui n'est pas appliquée
puisque il n'y a que deux ou trois
dispositions de cette loi qui sont
aujourd'hui du droit positif et nous
travaillons justement avec pragmatisme
et réalisme dans sa mise en oeuvre parce
qu'il est nécessaire de travailler avec
les investisseurs avec les
professionnels de retrouver la confiance
c'est le sens du programme de
responsabilité et de solidarité que nous
avons mis en place et nous allons
travailler dans ce sens et ce que le
message de confiance que je délivrerai
demain à lyon le centre département
merci la parole à françois patriat
pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur ministre de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt ça n'est pas une question
purement technique comme certains
pourraient le penser il s'agit d'une
question qui intéresse une filière qui
apporte beaucoup à la contribution
financière de la france en matière de
notoriété mais aussi d'emploi et
d'économie saisi de la filière
vitivinicole dont vous savez qu'elle est
très mobilisée depuis 2008 depuis que la
commission a décidé de libéraliser les
droits de plantation de notre pays tout
le monde s'est mobilisé les viticulteurs
les vignerons les professionnels les
élus locaux les élus nationaux les
parlementaires aussi avec d'autres
parlementaires européens pour faire en
sorte de s'élever contre cette
dérégulation qui le menace demain notre
la qualité de notre potentiel et
monsieur mehdi je voudrais vous
remercier d'avoir su réunir dans la
négociation pour la pac les états autour
de vous pour obtenir une majorité
pour que cette libéralisation soit
remise en cause et qu'on en revienne un
système d'autorisation qui permet de
garder la qualité de notre potentiel
mais qui dit nicole mais il s'agit
maintenant de passer aux actes
d'application et ce sont les actes
délégués et les actes d'exécution par
ses actes la commission tente
aujourd'hui de détourner la décision que
vous avez obtenus en permettant une
libéralisation déguisé je m'explique les
vins qui sont sans sa hausse et et 106 g
péta lire les 24 pourrait demain être
plantées sur des territoires ddt aoc et
à partir du moment où ils respectent les
règlements de ces territoires il
pourrait obtenir de façon déguisée
l'appellation d'origine contrôlée ou li
gp sans que les professionnels ils
puissent quelque chose en deuxième lieu
nous pourrions voir demain des vignes
arrachées autour de 24 dans une certaine
partie du territoire je ne cite aucune
mais replantés dans les territoires
comme la bourgogne où le bourg de l'est
sur des territoires aoc et qui
obtiendrait aussi de façon déguisée
demain de la 2d 20 avec appellation ce
qui ferait que quelques dizaines de
milliers d'hectolitres risquerait de
menacer de menaces et demain les
équilibres économiques que nous tentons
de préserver vous avez réussi monsieur
le ministre a aujourd'hui à réunir une
plateforme avec treize états mais il
semble que la commission voight aller au
bout dans cette démarche je vous demande
donc aujourd'hui comment nous pouvons
vous accompagne et vous aider ou
vous-même mener des actions pour pouvant
faire en sorte que cette libéralisation
ne soit pas mené à son terme mais plus
nous restions bien conforme à la
décision que vous avez courageusement
obtenu autour de la réforme de la pac je
vous remercie merci la parole à stéphane
le foll ministre l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de la forêt monsieur
le président monsieur le sénateur
françois patriat vous avez d'abord
rappelé la bataille qui était celle que
nous avons conduite sur la question des
droits de plantation quelle est l esprit
de cette bataille de la remise en cause
de l'accord qui avait été signé en 2008
sur la suppression de ces droits de
plantation la suppression des droits de
plantation dans l'esprit de la
commission et de ce qu'il avait signé
c'était de permettre à l'europe
développer sa production viticole pour
pouvoir accéder au marché mondial marché
mondial vous le savez du vin qui se
développe et qui continue à voir la
consommation de vin s'accroître avec un
risque ça a été rappelé qu'en
développant les plantations de vignes
sans aucune régulation on finisse par
remettre en cause ce qui est l'enjeu
majeur du vin sa qualité son origine ses
aoc et l'ensemble de saisie gp c'était
bien ça l'objectif on a remis en cause
le projet de la commission et la
bataille a lieu maintenant non pas sur
l'esprit qui était le nôtre de revenir
justement sur cette lavier
libéralisation dans les actes délégués
c'est comment on applique ce retour à
des droits de plantation et c'est dans
ces actes délégués me l'avait
parfaitement indiqué que la bataille est
engagée avec la commission pour faire en
sorte qu'on ne revienne pas de manière
déguisée sur ce qui avait été proposé en
2008 et que nous avions contesté remis
en cause avec le retour des
présentations il ya plusieurs critères
sur lesquels il faut qu'on se battre
j'ai envoyé une lettre au commissaire
européen sur ce sujet à la fois sur les
questions de régionalisation de ses
droits les capacités qu'on a à prendre
un certain nombre de critères en
particulier la question des cépages la
question aussi de la production de la
productivité les niveaux de plantation
autant d'éléments qui doivent être
intégrées avec un seul objectif éviter
qu une replantation sans aucune
régulation finissent pas remettre en
cause les aoc les iger p parce que c'est
ça qui est l'enjeu un plan stratégique
m'a été présenté ce matin l'ensemble de
la profession vitivinicole française à
travailler sur qu'est ce qu'on
souhaitait pour les années qui viennent
à la fois protéger les ige paix et les
aoc et développer aussi une partie d'une
production viticole qui fait défaut
aujourd'hui à la france en particulier
je le disais au niveau de l'exportation
et surtout sur les vins de cépage il
faut qu'on soit conscient que la
bataille immédiate c'est les actes
délégués mais qu'on aura tous ensemble
tous ensemble ceux qui connaissent le
vin des différentes régions à faire en
sorte qu'en france
l'application de cette nouvelle règle de
ces nouvelles règles se fasse dans une
cohérence pour l'ensemble du vignoble
français j'ai connu et vous avez connu
aussi des concurrences entre les régions
il faut qu'on soit capable d'assumer nos
responsabilités
donc je vous demande le soutien pour la
négociation en cours sur les actes
délégués et demain sur l'organisation
merci du marché viticole français merci
la parole à jean luc fichet
pour le groupe socialiste
ma question s'adresse au ministre
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire de la
forêt monsieur le ministre depuis
plusieurs mois l'activité industrielle
agroalimentaire bretonne souffre
particulièrement dans le domaine du port
mais aussi de la volaille le
gouvernement et vous même monsieur le
ministre très au fait des difficultés
rencontrées
vous vous êtes régulièrement déplacés en
bretagne des aides ont été débloqués
pour soutenir les filières des moyens
d'accompagnement des hommes et des
femmes qui ont perdu leur emploi ont été
mises en oeuvre l'état s'est engagé
concrètement auprès des ex salariés de
gad avec une allocation de reconversion
professionnelle pendant un an un suivi
dans la recherche d'emploi avec un
conseiller pôle emploi pour 20 salariés
au chômage
pour autant la bretagne doit aujourd'hui
faire face à la remise en cause complète
de toute une filière et d'un modèle de
développement économiques en matière
d'agro alimentaire
la période de transition vers ce nouveau
modèle économique risque d'être longue
des projets émergent comme celui de
lampaul agro qui propose la reprise du
site d'abattage de porcs de lampaul
guimiliau ce dossier suscite de l'espoir
qu'elle soutient votre gouvernement
peut-il encore apporter sachant que nous
attendons aussi beaucoup de la
solidarité professionnelle pour voir
c'est 250 emplois de l'an pôle agro se
concrétiser rapidement la filière
volaille souffrent également sur le
territoire du pays de morlaix à
guerlesquin même les salariés de
l'entreprise sissoko se mobilisent pour
le maintien de leur outil de travail
deuxième exportateur de poulet français
le volailler est toujours suspendu aux
aides financières et ses 340 employés
sont très inquiets de cette situation
critique
après dix-huit mois de redressement
judiciaire le sort du volailler doux
n'est toujours pas scellé toutefois en
parallèle sans faire de bruit de
nombreuses pme ont pris le chemin de
l'innovation et de la valeur ajoutée
dans le secteur agroalimentaire je pense
à savéol à wau à sodebo est encore à
père dodu mais il faut encore du temps
pour que l'ensemble du secteur se
redresse c'est donc une dynamique
collective qui seule permettra de
retrouver les conditions d'une dynamique
solidaire pour l'économie bretonne et
l'emploi pouvez vous nous dire monsieur
le ministre quel est votre perception de
la situation à ce jour de
l'agroalimentaire en bretagne je
remercie
merci monsieur stéphane le foll ministre
de l'agriculture le président monsieur
le sénateur fichiers vous avez évoqué ça
donne deux points
sur la lecture ou plutôt de
l'agroalimentaire breton
vous avez cité deux filières la filière
volaille et la filière porcine sur la
filière volaille est concernée
directement cette filière qu'on appelle
filière export de volaille qui vous
l'avez dit connaît des difficultés pas
simplement depuis quelques mois depuis
plusieurs années et quand nous sommes
arrivés aux responsabilités il s'est
trouvé que le redressement judiciaire de
doubs a été engagée et la fragilité de
l'autre opérateur sissako et toujours
aujourd'hui une réalité qu'est ce que
nous faisons premier point premier
message il y a un avenir pour une
filière export de poulet en particulier
en bretagne ça c'est le premier point de
une fois qu'on a dit ça il fallait
éviter la dégradation de la situation de
doute c'est ce que nous avons fait avec
un fonds de retournement et avec la
mobilisation des acheteurs en
particulier saoudien nous avons mobilisé
aussi les moyens de l'état en créant de
fiducie pour donner des moyens à tilly
sabco de tenir pour éviter sa
liquidation ou ses difficultés
rien aujourd'hui ne nous garantit à
terme la viabilité économique actuel
toute la stratégie est fait pour faire
venir des opérateurs industriels
français pour pouvoir investir est
relancé
une filière export dont je dit owni
aujourd'hui au sénat qu'elle a un avenir
il ya des marchés au moyen de renom qui
sont extrêmement importants nous devons
nous organiser
mais les acteurs économiques qui sont
mobilisés doivent aussi se mobiliser
pour trouver la solution sur cette
filière export le deuxième point c'est
la filière porcine ça remonte à loin la
baisse de la production qui voit
aujourd'hui grâce aux mesures que nous
avons prises en particulier sur les
établissements classés avec la procédure
d'enregistrement se redresser puisque un
abattoir fonctionne avec le d'animaux
abattus quand vous avez moins d'animaux
les structures d'abattage se retrouve
mise en difficulté c'est qu'en bretagne
nous avons perdu à peu près 6 à 7 à 8 %
de ce qui était la production de 2010 je
parle pas d'augmenter la production pour
l'augmenter 2010 comme base l'objectif
c'est d'y revenir et pas d'aller au-delà
pour structurer des structures
d'abattage vous avez évoqué lampaul
guimiliau vous le savez un abattoir a
été fermé il ya un projet effectivement
qui est en discussion en même temps que
à josselin j'ai un abattoir qui connaît
aussi des difficultés
des réunions ont été faites et en
particulier la région pour mettre
l'ensemble des acteurs autour de la
table pour trouver des solutions
communes collectif parce que c'est comme
ça qu'on y arrivera aujourd'hui il faut
qu'on fasse le constat que nous n'avons
pas encore trouvé la solution est donc
cette réflexion elle est en cours avec
une volonté redresser la production pour
derrière assurer la pérennité des outils
de transformation
merci la parole est à présent à robert
le fond au loup pour le groupe union
pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président madame messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des affaires sociales la santé et porte
sur la santé dans les autres mers dans
un tout récent rapport la cour des
comptes fait une présentation alarmant
de la situation sanitaire dans les outre
mer français
constatant les difficultés des
difficultés persistantes une prévention
est suffisante et des systèmes de santé
à la peine la cour a elle que la
république si elle respecte les
spécificités de chacun est néanmoins une
et indivisible et que l'état de veiller
à ce que soit assuré l'égalité de chacun
dans le domaine de la santé il est
souligné par exemple que wallis et
futuna est la seule partie de la france
où l'espérance de vie recule cela est
d'autant plus choquant que la dépense
courante de santé par habitant y est la
plus basse et où l'état de santé de la
population et le plus dégradé de tout
l'outre-mer et de toute la république la
cour formule 14 recommandations
visant à agir plus efficacement pour la
santé en outre-mer selon une stratégie
d'ensemble et pluri annuel permettant de
réduire les écarts les écarts les plus
graves en termes d'accès aux toits et
l'égalité des chances
qu'elle suit compte donner le
gouvernement à ces diverses
recommandations
il stratégie d'ensemble d'autres outils
d'évaluation régulier sera telle mise en
place et concernant la 13e
recommandations recommandations qui
demande que la dette de la chance de
santé de wallis et futuna soit apurer au
plus vite le président bayle qu'on est
bien ce dossier sur lequel nous a
soutenus quel calendrier comp
comptez-vous mettre en place car les
mois qui passent en nano sera purement
non concrétisées malgré les promesses
formulées publiquement par le président
de la république font courir des risques
accrus sur la santé déjà précarisées des
populations démolissez futuna je vous
remercie
merci pour vous répondre jean marie le
guen secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations avec le parlement merci
monsieur le président la met messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
robert lofo à lui je vous prie de bien
vouloir excuser marisol touraine qu'il
ne peux vous répondre cet après-midi en
raison d'un empêchement vous interroger
le gouvernement sur rapport de la cour
des comptes sur la santé outre-mer je
crois que c'est un rapport qui a frappé
tous les esprits regard à la fois de la
situation qu'ils présentaient du
caractère assez exhaustif de son
diagnostic il constitue donc un document
très complet se fondant sur un certain
nombre de constats en particulier sur la
nécessité des politiques de santé de
prendre en compte les spécificités
ultramarines que constitue l'éloignement
de l'hexagone bien sûr parfois l'
isolement les risques naturels les
cyclones les séismes l'existence de
populations fragilisées et surexposé à
certaines pathologies infectieuses ou
certaines pathologies aussi chronique où
la prévalence de certaines maladies
génétiques comme la drépanocytose
comme l'a rappelé avec force ce matin
marisol touraine lors de la présentation
des orientations de la stratégie
nationale de santé les actions en santé
notamment la prévention concernant
l'ensemble de nos territoires doit être
mise en oeuvre elle veillera donc à ce
que les avancées majeures contenues dans
le projet de loi santé soient appliquées
de manière adaptée car c'est bien ça la
question aux territoires d'outre-mer
pour ce qui est du second sujet auquel
vous faites référence le gouvernement
déplore tout particulièrement les
difficultés auxquelles sont confrontés
les wallisiens pour les soins auxquels
ils doivent recourrir le gouvernement
s'est engagé à consolider le
fonctionnement de l'agencé régionale de
wallis et futuna des moyens
supplémentaires en vue de limiter
l'endettement de lagence seront donc
allouée à lagence nous soutiendront
également les investissements
nécessaires pour assurer la prise en
charge sur place et limiter autant que
faire se peut les évacuations sanitaires
vous le voyez monsieur le sénateur le
gouvernement est vraiment mobilisés pour
la santé de l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes bien sûr mais et de nos
compatriotes ultramarins mai et tout
particulièrement pour la situation que
vous avez décrit avec beaucoup de force
de la situation de wallis et futuna qui
nous importe au premier rang merci merci
mes chers collègues nous avons fini avec
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h15 pour la suite
de la discussion de la proposition de
loi tendant à moderniser diverses niveau
dispositions de la législation
applicable dans le département de la
moselle du bas rhin et du haut rhin la
séance est suspendue
voilà comme l'a dit le président jean
pierre bel la séance est suspendue nous
on se retrouve pour refaire la séance
merci à tous de nous rejoindre sur
public sénat pour refaire la séance on
va débriefer séance des questions
d'actualité
elles sont nombreuses des questions
d'actualité pour ce faire françois
patriat est avec nous bonjour vous êtes
président de la région bourgogne
sénateurs socialistes on va parler de la
région bien évidemment d'abord je
voudrais vous entendre un peu son climat
social sur cette grève sncf sur les
intermittents a entendu beaucoup de
questions notamment sur les
intermittents du spectacle comment vous
voyez-vous ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
cette première crise sociale pour le
gouvernement or il ya une grande colère
sur le territoire concernant les grèves
autour du train puisque vous savez la
région est en charge des ter sont des
milliers de personnes qui tous les jours
travaille à l'intérieur de la bourgogne
où vont en région parisienne ou dans la
région lyonnaise ou ailleurs et qu'ils
disent au président de la région que la
situation est devenue dramatique
difficile onéreuse et qu'elle nous coûte
1 vous vivez tous les jours sur le
terrain depuis neuf jours ou en tant que
deux généraux de région qu'est-ce qui
vous disent les oiseaux on imagine qu'il
ya un ras-le-bol général mais est ce que
vous estimez aujourd'hui que l'action du
gouvernement est suffisante je crois que
le gouvernement a raison d'être
déterminée sur la loire et qu'il y a de
la part des syndicalistes une forme
d'irresponsabilité
à ce jour à faire croire aux usagers et
aux clients qui sont les mêmes
d'ailleurs que le statut des cheminots
seraient remises en cause par les 3 epic
créé par la loi alors que il n'en est
rien un examen est violent ce moment à
l'assemblée nationale voilà le rappeler
pour ceux qui l'examen a poursuivi la
loi va être votée ce soir moi je
souhaite que dans ce domaine le
gouvernement qui a écouté les
syndicalistes qui a pris en compte un
certain nombre de leurs demandes
notamment au niveau du comité central
qui sera dans l'épique centrale j'espère
que cette grève prendra fin ce soir ou
demain matin en quelques mots sur les
attaquants les intermittences avec eux
nous sommes aussi une terre de culture
une terre de
spectacle de nombreux autour du
patrimoine bourguignon et il est vrai
que si nous avons réussi à sauvegarder
les spectacles en bourgogne aujourd'hui
et les festivals si demain à la suite du
rapport qui sera remis ce soir premier
ministre quelques avancées autour de
celle de cet accord qui doit malgré tout
être signé par le gouvernement il va de
soi que les craintes sont nombreuses
mais que j'espère qu'il y aura un
apaisement dans les heures qui viennent
aussi je veux quand même d'un mot sur la
façon dont ces géré par le gouvernement
droit dans ses bottes manuel valls ça
peut suffire s'il n'est pas droit dans
ses bottes parce que le gouvernement ne
peut pas faire autrement que d'accepter
un accord qui est un accord paritaire
aujourd'hui le gouvernement dans le même
temps a maintenu le dialogue il dit je
dois signer mais s'il ya des
améliorations à faire je suis prêt à les
entendre si elles sont conformes à
l'esprit de la loi et à l'accord qu'a
eue qui a eu à l'unedic je crois que
certaines ouvertures pourront être
faites de façon à ce que ce conflit là
aussi se développe parce que c'est vrai
que dans les difficultés actuelles que
connaît notre pays dans le contexte
économique et social il va de soi que
ces conflits à répétition ajoute ajoute
au mécontentement ambiant à la ajoutent
à ce climat un peu délétère qu'il ya
dans notre pays aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est contre cela qu'il nous faut
aujourd'hui travailler tous ensemble
pour y arriver on avait un petit peu sur
ce texte sur les régions sont les
départements les communes bref sur la
réforme du territoire il ya une
commission spéciale qui va être créé au
sénat